-Isabel Eriksson, welcome.
-Thank you.
This story starts when you meet a man
for the second time in your apartment.
What did you know about this man?
He said he lived in London
and worked within finance.
He was well built.
He was a little bit shorter than me.
He seemed calm and collected.
He seemed intelligent.
He had brought with him-
-strawberries dipped in chocolate
and champagne.
He had laced the berries
with a sleeping agent.
What do you remember from that night?
I remember that he wanted
to feed me strawberries.
It's hard to talk about.
I fell asleep soon after,
and everything went black.
-He then put you in his car.
-Yes.
He took you to southern Sweden.
What did you see when you woke up?
I saw a tin roof-
-and a man sitting on a chair next to me.
He was just looking at me.
I had a needle in my arm. I ripped it out.
He said he had kidnapped me and wanted
to keep me for a couple of years.
A couple of years?
So he told you what his plans were?
-Yes.
-You had quite a strong reaction.
Yes, I tried to attack him and escape.
I attacked him with two nails.
But I was still drugged,
so it didn't go well.
He grabbed my wrists-
-and said that if I tried that again,
he would chain me to the bed-
-and only feed me crispbread.
How did you feel? You didn't know if you
were above or below the ground.
It was an unfinished room-
-with a lot of dust.
It was cold, dusty,
with stone floors
and bags of cement everywhere.
He told me he built it all himself.
He told me in detail how he had built it.
He seemed very proud of it.
-There were three vault doors.
-Yes.
Two of them had an electronic code lock.
Did he ever let you out-
-so you could get some fresh air?
Yes, he let me out sometimes.
He had built a little exercise yard...
Outside the bunker.
Can you see where you are?
No. I can only see trees.
So I have no idea where I am.
He took you dog with him. A small dog.
How did he treat it?
He took her for walks every morning.
One day he came in
with a black plastic box-
-and said that she would have to
do her business in the box.
If not, he would get rid of her.
-The dog was important to you.
-Yes, very.
One day he came in with a mask on.
He had bought some masks.
His plan was to wear it
during the abduction.
Was that to scare you?
I don't understand.
-One day he came in...
-An authentic looking mask.
Yes, it looked very genuine.
It didn't look like him.
I didn't know who entered the room.
I told him I had been kidnapped
and that I was being held captive.
I was hoping this person could help me.
But then he removed the mask-
-and I saw that it was him.
He said I looked very surprised.
-Did he find it funny?
-Yes, it was some kind of joke.
Did he have mood swings?
Yes. He was very calm-
-and intimidating at the same time.
He came in with a gun on the Monday.
He wanted me to shoot him.
-He wanted you to shoot him?
-Yes.
He gave me the gun
and told me that the doors were open-
-and I could just shoot him and leave.
But I couldn't shoot anyone.
And I didn't know if the doors
were really open.
On Friday he came back with the gun-
-and told me he wanted me to shoot him.
Did he tell you why he wanted you
to shoot him? Is he depressed?
He told me he could never
survive in prison.
So he wanted me to shoot him.
But it wasn't a real gun.
He wanted to test my intentions.
So I'm glad I never pulled the trigger.
You realized
that the place was escape proof.
Only he knew the codes.
So you were dependent on him.
If anything were to happen to him,
you'd never get out.
That's right.
What was your survival strategy?
I tried to escape when I first arrived.
But I realized I wouldn't
be able to overpower him.
The bunker was escape proof,
so I couldn't get out.
So I had to start playing my cards right.
I didn't want him to see me as a threat.
So I chose to be courteous and neutral.
I thought that might make him trust me-
-so that I could find
an opportunity to escape.
You're here today,
so it must have been a good strategy.
I don't believe you had sex in the bunker.
But he stayed with you one night.
Can you tell us about that?
Yes, he wanted us to sleep together.
It was horrible to sleep next to
someone who had kidnapped you.
He wanted body contact all night.
He has a plan.
He wants you to be his girlfriend.
But he doesn't initiate sex.
Do you have any idea why?
Yes, he took some tests.
Blood tests and such.
He wanted to make sure
I didn't have any diseases.
Because he wanted to have
unprotected sex.
When we slept together that Wednesday,
he didn't want to have sex
until the test results were back.
What did he do when he wasn't with you?
Did he work?
Did he have a normal life as a doctor?
Yes, he was working as a doctor.
His plan is for this to be long term.
-He also plans to kidnap more women.
-Yes.
But he couldn't do it.
And one day he tells you
that you're free to go.
Did he tell you why he couldn't do it?
Yes, on the Friday
he went back to Stockholm.
He was picking up my belongings
from my apartment.
He found a note on my door
which said I was missing-
-and that the police
had changed the locks, so he can't get in.
So he came back to the bunker-
-and told me to tell them I was with him
of my own free will-
-and that we would make up a story.
That he hadn't kidnapped me, but that
I was with him of my own free will.
So he wanted you to come with him
to the police to get your keys?
Yes, and to prove
that I hadn't been kidnapped.
How was the drive to Stockholm?
I tried to stay calm.
I had no idea what he was going to do.
If he was going to show the police
I was fine-
-and then kidnap me again.
I was terrified the entire time
and didn't know what he was going to do.
-Did you have a conversation?
-Yes.
What did he want to talk about?
Anything and everything.
He told me he didn't expect me
to be as nice as I was.
He said that if I hadn't been so nice,
he wouldn't have let me out.
Then I would have deserved
to stay in there.
-He came with you to the police station.
-Yes.
You had to wait for two hours.
It was an absurd situation.
Yes, it was.
-Did you feel free?
-No.
When did you feel free?
When I came into a room
to talk to an investigator.
-And he wasn't allowed in?
-No.
That's when I broke down-
-and told them that I had been kidnapped-
-and that the kidnapper
was sitting right there.
That's when they arrested him.
-He was arrested and later convicted.
-Yes.
You met this doctor because
you were working as an escort.
-And he was a client.
-Yes.
-You don't do that anymore.
-No.
-Would you be able to do that job again?
-No, absolutely not.
When I was working as an escort,
I had to lead a double life.
It was difficult
to have serious relationships.
Since the kidnapping I see life
differently and have different values.
What kind of help have you received?
I'm still in therapy to process
what happened to me.
Has it changed you as a person,
compared to what you were like
before this happened?
Yes, I've changed a lot.
I stopped working
as an escort immediately.
I realized what's important in life.
Before this happened,
easy money and travel-
-were important to me.
But now I have
completely different values.
I used to be
very fearless and adventurous.
But now I'm more scared and cautious.
You're a more cautious person.
What are your plans for the future?
I want to study. Maybe abroad.
Right now I'm focusing on taking it
one day at a time and get my life back.
The doctor will be released one day.
What are your thoughts on that?
I'm very scared.
It's terrifying knowing
that he will be released soon.
I'm under witness protection,
and will continue to be for a while.
Thank you very much
for telling us your story.
Your book is called
"I bunkerläkarens våld".
It's out now.
Thank you very much for coming.